- On this episode we talk
video email,
Facebook notes
and Eeyore employees.
Yeah, that Winnie the Pooh--
(hip hop music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is
The #AskGaryVee Show
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 132
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
So I really enjoy the random
tweets and Instagram comments,
Facebook comments
of people missing the show.
That makes me happy.
Obviously, I'm in the
midst of some vacation time
it's kind of a working week vacation,
spending it with my family
but in the office today.
I will be back in the
office next Wednesday night.
Are we taping on Thursday of next week?
So we'll get one more in.
So it's gonna be a little sporadic here.
The heart is going to grow very fond
as we are in a little bit of a hiatus
as I take family time.
I do feel itchy fingers.
Itchy fingers?
I do feel itchy fingers to possibly have
some of you guys come
and visit me out east.
One, I think we may have to actually work
on the book a little bit
and do that day.
And then maybe you can schlep
along and we can bang out
an episode on location.
But for the most part I
appreciate the momentum,
I'm really excited
as we get back into full swing.
We will be very focused on
football talk on the show.
Get ready for it.
And those things.
The other thing that
really excites me, India
is that I see you have your shirt.
Which really is cool.
- You don't have yours?
- No, I took it with me--
- Okay.
- and my dad stole mine.
- He stole it?
- No, I gave it to him
but it sounded to cooler
to say he stole, so.
India.
Oh, and by the way, real quick.
Some of you have been posting photos
of your wearing it. (fingers snap)
Which I like.
Which is a lot of fun.
Keep posting them,
we will keep showing them Vayner nation
in their show shirts
throughout the episodes
over the next 10 or 15 episodes.
So India,
Let's.
Get into.
The sh--
- Sho--
- Show. (laughs)
All right, let's do it.
- [India] Okay, first
question's from B. Lloyd.
- B. Lloyd.
- [India] Who is a lady.
- B. Lloyd (laughs)
B. Lloyd.
- [Voiceover] B. Lloyd asks,
"How do you and Eeyore employees?
"The ones that always sound like
"they're whining and pessimistic."
(laughs)
- We fire them.
Because energy is something
I value tremendously
and no question, if you
are dragging down the team,
that is a heavily--
Not having the smarts to do the work
is actually viewed as a better option
that being Eeyore and woe is me.
Look, we are 550 deep now,
I'm positive, as people are
watching this from VaynerMedia,
saying yeah but, "Ricky is really Eeyore."
You say you'd fire him,
why has Ricky been moping for six months?
I'm sure there's a couple
people sneaking through
with woe is me but the truth is
I heard a story this weekend from my mom,
we had an employee that was friends with--
My mom's friends with his mom
and she told me a story that
the doorman, and the doormen say
that they know who the
VaynerMedia employees are
versus not just by the pep in their step
when they go into the building
and they're happy and always smiling.
I think we have a pretty
good atmosphere here
and so I'm...
I'm very, very, very
affected by the atmosphere
and the energy of my own company
and since I'm the CEO
I try to create an
environment that allows me
to most do my thing.
And I think companies
are disproportionally
affected by the top five
to ten people in a company.
It's stunning,
if you even look at the
Apples and Nintendos
and Budweisers, I mean it's incredible
how a small group of people
really dictate the outcome.
And of course everybody's an impact
but for me, if I'm not in a good mood
because somebody's moping,
well then I (laughs), that's a problem.
There's a negative ROI there.
You know, the truth is,
we try to understand
what makes them unhappy.
Now, again, moping is different
than being and introvert or quiet.
You can be quiet and
focused on your thing.
That's very different
and I wanna make sure,
make a big point here that
I actually stunningly over-value
quiet, focused.
I always worry that people at VaynerMedia
don't realize if they're
an introvert or quiet
or focused or headphones on,
never really interacting.
We have such a culture
of intermingling that,
I would even argue that I value them,
not more, that's not fair.
I just value them for what they are.
I don't try to change
people for what they are.
And you could bring enormous
value to this company
by never saying a word or you can yell,
like Gabe, 24/7 and bring value.
All of it in between
really matters for me.
And so, let's make sure that
as you're watching this,
if your auditing your 5,
10, 15, 500 person company
that you're not digging
through and misjudging
moping and just quiet.
Or quiet and focused.
Or introverted.
Those are tremendously valuable things.
That's how they concentrate
and get their job done.
Moping is Debbie Downner.
I think it's more Debbie, whaa,
you know like Debbie
Downer like this sucks.
Try to walk around here for
more than 20 days in a row
saying this company sucks.
Try.
That's not gonna fly.
Being focused, maybe not
being the most social flower
and going to every happy hour
and high fiving everybody
when you walk through here,
that's more than fine.
That should be acceptable.
That is acceptable at the highest levels.
But saying this sucks.
The client sucks.
This work sucks.
This sucks, this sucks.
Just doesn't work, it's
too much of a downer.
So, how do we deal with it?
We try to cut it out.
It's cancer.
Straight up cancer.
Cut the cancer.
This is cancer. (tongue clicks)
- [India] It's your finger?
- I hope it's not.
(laughs)
- [India] Glenn.
- Glenn.
- [India] It's the Snapchat--
(laughs)
Ask it.
- [Voiceover] Glenn asks,
"Is the Snapchat Discover
kind of like Billboards?
"There for everyone to see
"but people's attention is elsewhere."
- No, I don't think,
Glenn, that is the case.
I actually think it's more
like the Facebook newsfeed.
I think it's there
and it's in the front of your eye
and base on the data of people clicking
clearly the content there is valuable.
I think the thing that
you need to understand
about Facebook, excuse
me, Snapchat Discover
is it is content, it is not ads.
A billboard is an ad
and you and I and Alex,
let's show Alex 'cause
the shirt he's wearing,
just needs its own attention today.
Two days in a row he wore that shirt?
Alex, what the--
Oh, got it, got it.
(laughs)
- [India] He'd never
repeat a shirt. (laughs)
Snapchat Discover is content.
When you click that, you know,
ESPN or Cosmo or the Snapchat logo
you know you're about to get content.
You're not gonna get ads.
There'll be some ads mixed in.
That's a very different value proposition
than a billboard.
And we've been all kind of trained to know
that billboard doesn't bring me any value,
it's trying to sell me something.
Versus tv and print and radio,
the reason we tolerate and still enjoy it
is, okay, I'm gonna
get something of value.
I'm gonna have to suffer
through being sold to
which is why technology's
shifting away from that
is the big rub that I talk a lot about
but Discover platform for me
is a belief that it's there
as a billboard, sure it's
in your face, it's there
but what is behind it, is the variable.
Now if they program it
correctly, Daily Mail
all the people that program there,
the partners, Daily Mail, Cosmo, ESPN
or Snapchat itself.
If they program successfully,
you'll go there.
A la NBC, ESPN, ABC, A&amp;E.
When Walking Dead is what you program
and people wanna go
there, they'll go there.
When Schmuck-A-Ma-Ma-Ga tv show
that nobody wants to watch is there
you don't go there.
So the content is the variable.
Knowing that there's content behind that
makes it very different than a billboard.
Make sense, right?
- [India] Yeah.
From Zoltan.
- Zoltan. (bangs table)
That one deserves that.
That's the most, you know...
- [Voiceover] Zoltan asks,
"What do you think about
the revamp Facebook
"gave it's Notes platform?
"A Medium contender, maybe?"
- Zoltan.
First, I feel like Zoltan and I should
try to take on the world.
I feel like there's--(laughs)
Let's team up.
Kill the world.
Truth is, I haven't dug deep.
Obviously, I've been checked
out for the last 48 hours
with the fam and Notes kind of hit out.
Obviously I got pinged
by a lot of people here
especially 'cause I've been
pushing the longform thing.
We had a little bit of a conversation.
Andy mentioned that it's a link out thing.
I haven't really looked yet.
So the answer is, I
can't fully answer this.
Help me here real quick, India,
'cause I know you had a look at it.
Andy mentioned that it's linked out.
- When you post it, it shows up as a link.
- Kind of like if you did
YouTube or GaryVaynerchuk.com
- Yeah, but it actually
stays within Facebook.
- Got it.
So our point of view and
why we talked about that is,
when you guys see the box
image and the headline,
you know you're leaving
the Facebook environment.
That creates a friction point
that the longform post does not.
But I would say we'll probably even--
You know what, let's test a note today
and we'll follow up on 133, 134, 135.
I think Facebook has a very clear plan.
Let's be the layer on top
of the internet itself.
So if anything works, YouTube video.
Medium blog post.
If anything works,
let's have our version of it
and that's keeping everybody
in our walled garden
because we'll make a lot
of money if we do that.
And AOL is the only other
company that ever had
that kind of ecosystem in
the late 90's, mid-90's
when people where scared--
I was scared to go to the world wide web.
There was a button up
there and it was like,
the world wide web, forget it.
I was in an AOL world,
I'm like, that's spooky.
I'm staying in here, it's safe.
Facebook doesn't have that advantage,
people are more educated,
they know the web exists.
But in a mobile first world,
in a Instagram, Facebook, WhatsApp world
that's why they offered
3 billion for Snapchat.
If Facebook owned Snapchat right now,
they would own the entire--
Alex even got excited
and he keeps it chill.
I mean he said, "Pshhh." (laughs)
I don't know if you heard it.
They would own the ecosystem.
So they're 3/4 of the way.
There is some other players but,
YouTube, there's other players but...
I think Facebook's plan is obvious.
And I think in general,
it's very interesting
to watch them navigate.
I think it's proper
for maximizing business.
It's why I'm very bullish on the company.
It's why I haven't sold a
single share of the stock.
I bought it private before it went public,
not a share.
I'm a big believer in it.
Video time.
- TCustomz
- TCustomz, producer.
- Hey Gary Vee, Travis here.
- [Gary] Travis.
- I first I wanna say
thanks for all you do
with the #AskGaryVee Show.
Most definitely will be buying
the book when it releases.
Question for you, is you
talk a lot about the use
of Twitter Native Video
and I can personally say
I've seen a lot of really
great results with engagement.
It almost got my reamped
about using the Twitter platform again.
You foresee this type of
video response funtionality
being built in natively
in some of the more common
email clients anytime in the near future?
Would this be practical
for someone like you
who travels a lot and who has
a lot of mass email volume
to go through?
Would love to hear your
thoughts, thanks for your time.
- Travis, way to keep it tight.
He like went Bone Thugs on that.
(laughs)
Real fast.
I watched Straight Out
Of Compton last night.
- [Staphon] That was good.
- Oh my god, I loved it.
Loved it.
(sighs)
What I think is really interesting on that
is I made, (laughs) I wish Erik
Kastner was here right now.
Let's show Kastner's
Twitter profile @kastner.
K-A-S-T-N-E-R
Erik was the developer
that sat right next to me
that helped me build up WineLibrary.com
And I made a prediction to him in 2004
or five or six or seven
that all email would be video
in five to seven years.
I'm glad we weren't doing the
Ask #GaryVeeShow back then
'cause boy that highlight--
The lowlights of this show, by the way,
I can't wait for the
lowlights in a couple years
of all my wrong things in this
'cause those are fun too.
(laughs) Not really.
I think the answer's no.
I think that what people don't realize
is most people don't want to be on camera.
And this is a really interesting thing.
Now, what's happening right now
with everybody growing
up in selfie culture
and all these 15, 14, 13 year
olds just owning this move.
I do think that behavior's changing.
And I do think that video's upside
over a 15 to 30 year period,
15 to 30 years from now,
15 through 30 years from now
is very high because I think
we're training youngsters,
7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, to be more out.
(phone dings)
To be more in front of the camera,
it's not this kind of thing anymore.
I'm bullish on the concept.
I do think email is ripe for a change
in the next generation.
I think, you know, Gmail's
gotten heavy, it started off lighter.
I think there's some real opportunity.
I do think when you look at Slack
and how people use that in
companies to communicate,
I think a version of texting,
Twitter video and email,
the Frankenstein of that,
eight, nine years from now
has a real shot.
And then there's gonna be a technology
we don't understand, like holograms.
Like Princess Leia pops up
in Star Wars.
I'd like that even better, I'd be like,
yo, I could use my hands.
It'd be great.
So I think a lot of technology will come
and I do think there'll be change.
I do think that video and email clients
like Gmail and Apple mail
is gonna be smaller than you think
because people don't
like to go that route.
It actually takes longer
and I think time is the biggest asset.
I think people can type it
quicker than click, dah-dah-dah
And I think we're writing less.
You know, a lot more emoji's.
These guys will probably
laugh right now. (laughs)
My emails are tight.
(laughs)
They're very much in the
K, LOL, Cool, Go, Yes, No
I mean, I am keeping it tight.
When I write two to three
sentences, people are like,
Whoa.
I think time is the biggest variable
besides people's non want
to be in picture form.
Think of how many people don't wanna
take pictures of themselves.
They don't wanna see themselves.
That's a very big culture, underrated.
Especially for the generation
that's in the workforce now.
The younger generation I think
will change that over time.
- Oh, Rue, Ree, Rue.
I mean, I know him really well, I just--
- I know.
- I interact with him a lot.
I just don't know if he pronounces it Roo.
- [Voiceover] Rui asks,
"You don't talk much about Tumblr.
"Do you think it's losing relevance?"
- Yes.
You keep asking quest--
(laughs)
Yes, I do think it's losing relevance.
I think Tumblr lost its moment,
which is tough for me 'cause I was
an early investor in Tumblr.
I made a lot of money
when it sold to Yahoo!
but it's part of a bigger company
that's selling media in a traditional way
even though it's Yahoo!
And I think that it lost to Instagram
in the mobile translation
much like many people did.
It is still a very high
rated app in the app store,
if you look in the top 100, it's usually
around number 90 to 110.
But I do think it's losing relevance.
I think there's a lot
of people that love it,
it's still a very big platform
but I don't say huge growth in it.
I don't see it.
I think it's a niche now,
where a lot of creative
people are doing their thing,
it's a great creative outlet.
A lot of people are doing
their anonymous work on it.
But then Snapchat came along
and kinda created a world--
India, what's going on behind me?
- [India] Nothing, I was just waving to--
(slaps table)
- What, no, no, you were laughing before.
- [India] No, I wasn't.
- Okay, I'll have to watch
that part of the show.
(laughs)
I think, the show.
I do think Tumblr's lost its momentum
and would need to have
some real innovation
to get going again.
Yes, I don't talk about it a lot
because it's not atop of mind.
And it's a current show, right.
Like this is gonna always follow
the path of what I think is most going on.
Just wanna thank everybody
for watching the show.
I realized over this weekend,
little bit over the break
of just how much this
community means to me.
Really enjoyed the amount of people
that have jumped out of lurkerville
and started commenting,
it really means a lot to me.
It is absolutely my oxygen,
in lieu of the financial aspects.
As many books as I sell of Ask Gary Vee,
the time commitment doesn't work mathwise
so I ask myself, what is it really?
And I think it's our interaction.
And I definitely think
it's our interaction.
Thank you so much for a lot
of people that jumped out
over the weekend and said, "I'm a lurker,
here's my comment on the latest show."
Question of the day.
What do I wanna know about?
Labor Day's coming up.
It's so funny these questions
of the day are becoming harder
because I really don't
know what I want to know.
They've become less self- serving
from a datas perspective.
Question of the day.
When is your fav--
I guess, I'm going self-serving.
What is your favorite football team?
And what, after one preseason game,
is the prediction for your
team's record this year?
Side note, I may change
question of the day.
As a matter of fact, I'm changing it.
Right here on the spot,
we're going improv.
No more question of the day, this is it.
This will be part of the--
This is 132?
This will be part of
the quiz game one day.
What episode did it go
from question of the day
to comment of the day.
Please make your comment on the content
that you just watched.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)